Natacha Polony bonjour.
Bonjour.
Nous vous recevons aujourd'hui pour une chaîne YouTube qui s'apelle Thinkerview. On voudrait avoir votre avis sur le journalisme.
Vous avez créé récemment un thinktank qui s'appelle... Vous avez assumé la présidence d'un thinktank qui s'appelle le Comité Orwell.
Qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire?
C'est un comité qui s'est fondé à quelques journalistes...
Des noms? Parce que sur votre site internet c'est pas très bien fait, on arrive pas à avoir accès à toutes les informations du board de ce thinktank là.
Alors c'est très simple, sur une idée originale de Jean-Michel Quatrepoint, Alexande Devecchio qui est au Figaro et au Figaro-vox,
Emmanuel Lévy qui est à Marianne, Franck Dedieu qui est à l'Expansion et... Voilà, à prori la petite équipe de départ c'était ça.
Benjamin Masse-Stramberger aussi.
Et puis on a comme ça, au fur et à mesure, agglutiné les énergies, pourquoi?
Parce qu'au départ c'était des discussions entre-nous, où nous nous disions que le journalisme tel qu'il est pratiqué ne nous plaisait pas.
Que nous avions cette sensation assez désagréable que certains sujets ne sont jamais traités ou ne sont pas traités comme ils devraient l'être.
Qu'il y a, non pas une chappe de plomb comme ça a pu être le cas à un moment donné, vraiment je pense, dans les années 1990-2000...
Chappe de plomb idéologique alors là, épouvantable.
Les choses ont bougé mais en tout cas, qu'il y avait et qu'il y a, une façon de ne pas poser les problèmes,
de ne pas les traiter, qui est la négation de l'idée qu'on se faisait du journalisme.
Donc nous avons eu envie de réfléchir à la pratique journalistique,
de réfléchir à la façon dont les idées pouvaient être agitées, dont les informations pouvaient sortir.
Nous avons lancé un texte, une sorte de manifeste et ce manifeste a recueilli énormément d'écho.
Qu'est-ce que vous appellez énormément d'écho?
Enormément d'écho ça veut dire...
4500 abonnés sur votre page Facebook?
Voilà, des...
240 abonnés sur votre page YouTube?
Exactement...
305 vues sur votre colloque d'ouverture?
Oui, il me semble que d'arriver à mobiliser 250 personnes dans un colloque, c'est quand-même pas non plus quelque chose d'évident.
On a reçu énormément de messages de gens nous disant "Bravo, merci de réfléchir à ça".
Je pense qu'il y a aujourd'hui une insatisfaction énorme de la part des français sur ce que sont les média.
Il y a une impression de ne pas être informés, une impression que...
Une trahison?
Oui, oui réellement, une forme de trahison et l'idée que les média jouent un rôle de chien de garde
Donc je pense que...
Chien de garde de qui?
Chien de garde d'un système. Chiens de garde de... On va dire d'un système qui,
pour reprendre la phrase de Warren Buffett, est une véritable lutte des classes et que les riches sont en train de gagner.
Je pense qu'il y a de ça.
Vous avez posé des question à Christine Okrent concernant les réseaux de pouvoirs. Le cercle Bilderberg.
Oui.
Comment ça vous est venu à l'esprit?
Nous personnellement on les connait. On a travaillé avec certains qui ont participé au Bilderberg, y compris de la commission trilatérale.
On reçoit souvent Hervé de Carmoy qui était vice-président de la commission trilatérale Europe.
Ce sujet des cercles de pouvoirs n'est vraiment pas abordé.
Ca vous est venu à l'idée comment comment et... La réaction qu'elle a eu en face de vous, c'était naturel? C'était comment?
C'était violent on va dire. Je pense qu'elle s'en souvient encore.
Elle vous a pris pour une conne?
Non seulement elle m'a prise pour une conne, mais elle m'a prise surtout pour quelqu'un qui n'avait pas à poser ce genre de questions
et qui tout à coup faisait surgir quelque chose qui ne doit pas surgir au milieu d'un débat convenu entre gens bien.
Le "Ronron" ?
C'est ça ! Mais vous savez, c'est valable pour ce genre de questions, pour comment ça m'est venu de parler du réseau Bilderberg,
parce que tout simplement, j'ai lu en travaillant sur elle qu'elle en avait fait partie.
Je me suis posé la question de savoir quelle était la place d'un journaliste dans ce genre de cercles.
Qu'est-ce qu'on venait y chercher.
Pourquoi est-il très sain qu'un journaliste soit dans les mêmes réseaux de fréquentation et d'influence que des chefs d'entreprise, des politiques?
Est-ce que réellement, ça lui rapporte de l'information?
Non. Il n'y a aucun but informatif là-dedans puisque justement le principe est que ce qui y est dit ne sorte pas.
Donc ce n'est pas pour aller chercher de l'information.
Ce n'est pas pour aller comprendre le fonctionnement des systèmes politiques et économiques,
parce que je pense qu'on peut les comprendre parfaitement sans cela. Donc c'est quoi?
Est-ce que vous avez déjà assisté à un type de réunion de cette ampleur-là, de ce niveau-là?
Non. Honnêtement non.
Est-ce que vous avez déjà été dans un cercle de ce niveau-là?
Non. Très honnêtement non.
Mais je pense que je n'y serais pas pour une raison simple, c'est que justement je ne pratique pas mon métier de journaliste de cette façon.
C'est à dire que je ne pense pas que la proximité avec les hommes politiques par exemple, m'apporte quoi que ce soit dans ma façon
de traiter les questions politiques et de réfléchir aux rôles que jouent les politiques, aux choix qui sont les leurs.
Vos collègues, le "sérail journalistique", a fait corps avec vous derrière ou vous a laissé... dans la nature?
Comment vous dire? J'ai toujours été un peu à part dans les milieux journalistiques où j'ai travaillé
peut-être parce que justement je n'ai pas un parcours de journaliste. Je n'ai pas fait d'école de journalistes.
Moi j'ai une aggrégation de lettres, alors évidemment j'ai fait Sciences-Po aussi, mais à un moment où j'avais déjà enseigné, où j'étais professeure...
Donc mon parcours il est plus aggreg' de lettres que Sciences-Po.
Et j'ai continué à enseigner ensuite en même temps que je pratiquais le journalisme.
Donc peut être que ça m'a donné une façon de traiter les problèmes assez différente.
On m'a parfois reproché, parmi mes collègues, de trop intellectualiser, de trop éditorialister.
C'est à dire qu'en effet, j'assume la pratique d'un journalisme d'opinion que j'ai appris à Marianne, avec Jean-François Kahn,
qui m'a toujours expliqué que c'est une tradition française ; que ça n'a jamais dérangé personne quand il s'agissait de Jaurès, de Clémenceau,
de tout ce que l'on veut et que c'est une façon de respecter le lecteur.
Il sait d'où l'on parle.
Pour revenir sur le comité Orwell et les journalistes, il y a un problème, ça c'est sûr.
La question que je vous ai posée quand j'ai été invité au comité Orwell c'est si le comité Orwell c'est-à-dire cette prise de conscience,
cette émergence de prise de conscience de la profession de fonctionne pas, qu'est-ce qu'il va se passer?
Et je vous ai répondu : la révolution. Et je le crois profondément.
C'est-à-dire que je pense, que dans ce que Christopher Lasch appelle la Sécession des élites,
c'est-à-dire le fait que nous avons aujourd'hui, partout dans le monde, des élites qui n'ont plus
les mêmes intérêts objectifs que les peuples des pays auxquels ils appartiennent, dans ce cadre-là,
si l'on continue à accepter cette fracture, à laisser se déliter, on va dire, le "bien commun"
et la préservation du bien commun au sein des nations, je pense qu'on va vers des mouvements violents.
Je pense qu'on sent une colère qui monte, une colère qui peut s'exprimer de façon très diverse, personne ne sait ce qu'il peut se passer.
Mais il est évident que les élections américaines, les élections françaises, les élections partout en Europe
nous montrent que les peuples cherchent, pour l'instant tout de même, à travers l'exercice démocratique, mais peut-être de moins en moins, à faire entendre leur voix.
A reprendre le pouvoir ou en tout cas, à faire comprendre aux élites qu'ils se sont aperçu qu'on leur avait pris le pouvoir.
Qu'on les prenait pour des cons tout simplement...
Oui, qu'on les prenait pour des cons, que les intérêts sont divergents, tout simplement.
Et qu'on s'assied sur la démocratie. Donc on ne peut pas s'asseoir sur la démocratie très longtemps, Il y a un moment où ça ne marche plus.
Les préconisations pour améliorer ça? S'il y a des conseils à faire passer à vos collègues?
Peut-être ma formation intellectuelle me pousserait-elle à dire que la première préconisation serait de lire.
Oui.
Serait de développer une culture générale, une curiosité qui permet d'avoir un tout petit peu de recul sur les discours qui sont produits.
Des petits cours d'auto-défense intellectuel?
Oui, c'est ça.
C'est quand-même grave de conseiller ça à un journaliste... Ils ont oublié ça? La charte de Munich?
Il y avait eu il y a quelques années dans Le monde diplomatique une enquête très intéressante
sur les écoles de journalisme. Je ne me rapelle pas le nom du journaliste...
C'est pas Bréville?
Oui, oui, mais il expliquait à quel point il y avait une chose qui manquait furieusement dans les écoles de journalisme, ce sont les bibliothèques.
Et je pense que c'est une des dimensions importantes du problème.
C'est à dire que jusqu'à présent, les journalistes, enfin le journalisme n'était pas tout à fait une profession comme les autres
Un jour je me suis pris la tête avec Servan-Schreiber, je lui objectais... c'était à l'époque de l'affaire Assange
et le partenariat entre les maisons de presse et Wikileaks pour traiter les câbles.
Et j'étais un petit peu en train de l'asticoter sur l'indépendance des journalistes et sa grande tirade a été
"Mais vous m'objectez l'indépendance des journalistes, moi durant ma longue carrière, je n'ai jamais senti la laisse du pouvoir se tendre sur les journalistes."
Là on est en 2016, est-ce qu'il y a une laisse au cou des journalistes?
C'est-à-dire que pour ne pas sentir la laisse se tendre, il suffit de ne pas tirer dessus. Donc on ne sent rien du tout...
Oui, pour sentir sa liberté, commencez à faire bouger vos chaînes...
Mais bien sûr qu'il y a une laisse, il y a une laisse, d'abord j'allais dire simplement économique.
La situation actuelle des média fait que les journalistes sont sous dépendance.
Parce qu'ils sont en permanence menacés de perdre leur travail, tout simplement.
Ce qui est en train de se passer dans le groupe de L'express et L'expansion c'est une saignée absolue.
C'est à dire qu'on a des journalistes qui aujourd'hui se retrouvent sur le carreau.
Une saignée ou une épuration?
Pour l'instant je dis une saignée parce que je ne sais pas exactement quels sont les choix qui sont à l'oeuvre. Mais en tout cas je pense en effet que ça relève de...
J'allais dire, je ne serais pas forcément immédiatement malveillante dans ma façon de prendre les choses.
Dans le sens où je ne pense pas forcément qu'il y ait une épuration idéologique
parce que je crois que malheureusement, l'idéologie première c'est l'économisme.
C'est à dire l'idée qu'on va réduire les coûts, tout ça est fait par des gens qui n'ont aucune notion de ce qu'est une entreprise de presse.
Qui se foutent totalement de la spécificité du travail d'un journaliste.
Mais ils continuent à investir dedans pourtant, ça perd du fric...
Alors, il reste encore une dimension de prestige et de poids politique dans le fait de posséder un média.
Ou de propagande?
Même si on perd du fric...
Même pas seulement de propagande. Même pas seulement.
C'est simplement l'idée que l'on pèse dans son rapport avec des politiques et avec d'autres milieux économiques.
C'est l'équivalent d'une chaîne YouTube avec beaucoup d'abonnés.
Voilà c'est ça, exactement.
On a reçu Denis Robert à plusieurs reprises, qu'est ce que vous pensez de Denis Robert?
Ecoutez... j'aurai du mal à avoir un jugement définitif parce que c'est quelqu'un que je n'ai jamais recontré.
J'ai suivi son travail. J'ai été intéressée par son travail, après je ne me prétendrai pas spécialiste du sujet.
Et j'ai horreur de parler quand je ne maîtrise pas suffisament ce dont je parle.
Vous n'avez pas vu son film "L'enquête"?
Non, je n'ai pas vu son film "L'enquête".
Donc vous êtes au courant de son travail, quand il a commencé à remuer un peu la merde
des chambres de compensation avec le Luxembourg, il s'est fait un peu lapider par votre corporation.
Comment ça se fait qu'il n'y a pas de solidarité entre les journalistes?
Oh, il y en a quand il faut, c'est-à-dire quand...
Quand il faut demander du fric !
Euh... Oui, ou quand il s'agit d'expliquer, de prendre des airs outrés parce que tel ou tel politique dénonce des journalistes trop proches du pouvoir.
Là tout à coup on a vraiment "Comment, mais vous attaquez les journalistes c'est un scandale".
Donc non non, il y a un corporatisme évident mais, en effet, il ne joue pas forcément là où il devrait.
On va prendre un dossier un peu plus frais, Paul Moreira, sur l'Ukraine, s'est fait  rammasser sur les réseaux sociaux côté journalistes,
s'est fait aduler par une grande partie de l'internet par rapport à son indépendance d'esprit, pour ceux qui ont vu son documentaire.
Votre avis là-dedans? En tant que présidente du comité Orwell? Est-ce qu'on a le droit de traiter tout les sujets?
Il est évident qu'on a pas le droit de traiter tous les sujets !
C'est-à-dire bien sûr qu'il y a un espèce de, on va dire de... pas de censure mais de, comment dire...
De façon très très claire de faire sentir qu'il a des choses dont on ne peut pas parler.
Et des choses qu'il ne faut pas aller fouiller. Que tout à coup on sort de ce qu'Alain Minc appelle "le cercle de la raison". M'voyez?
La police de la pensée?
Oui bien sûr, bien sûr. Et cette police de la pensée elle est extrêmement puissante dans la mesure où
Il s'agit avant tout de faire passer celui qui a débordé des limites pour...
Pour un conspirationniste?
Pour un conspirationniste, un incompétent, un... quelqu'un qui tout à coup n'a rien à faire à la table des gens sérieux.
Vous connaissez Arthur Schoppenhauer?
Arthur Schoppenhauer? Oui.
"L'art d'avoir toujours raison"
Oui bien sûr.
Vous n'avez pas l'impression que c'est un petit peu le livre de chevet de tous ces intellectuels médiatiques?
C'est prendre le contrôle de la dialectique grâce à des stratagèmes.
Alors, à ceci-près que qu'est-ce qu'on appelle "intellectuel médiatique" et qui désigne-t-on par là?
C'est-à-dire que le concept d'intellectuel médiatique en ce moment, il est utilisé aussi pour...
Disons comme une arme pour décrédibiliser certains, c'est un concept à géométrie variable, "intellectuel médiatique".
Quand l'intéllectuel médiatique c'est BHL [Bernard-Henri Lévy] ou Alain Minc, finalement ça ne dérange pas.
Mais en ce moment, ce qu'on appelle "intellectuel médiatique" c'est ce que Najat Vallaud-Belkacem a appelé les "pseudo-intellectuels"
c'est à dire ceux qui pensent mal, ceux qui ont eu le mauvais goût de critiquer la réforme du collège.
Et là tout à coup "intellectuel médiatique" était une forme de dévalorisation. Donc c'est pour ça que le concept me pose problème.
Alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour aller récupérer cette indépendance d'esprit, aller traiter les sujets nécessaires pour avoir un prisme de lecture profond?
On fait un syndicat de journalistes sur-armés intellectuellement parlant? On fait des groupes de pression?
On fait quoi? Qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire pour... Nous on a tendance un peu à ravager votre profession,
Ils savent pertinemment que quand ils viennent commenter les choses chez nous, s'ils n'ont pas l'étoffe ou la trempe d'un Denis Robert, ils se font vaporiser.
On aimerait quand-même un peu vous aider. On fait quoi nous l'internet? On va protéger les journalistes?
On fait le boulot de... on fait quoi? Qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire pour vous aider?
Je pense que le travail que vous faites, le travail qui se trouve sur internet ne doit pas venir en aide aux journalistes.
C'est une alternative, c'est une autre façon de produire de l'information et de la pensée.
Simplement moi j'ai une attache pour le journalisme classique et en particulier de presse écrite,
dont je pense que pour l'instant, il n'est pas encore remplacé, son rôle exact ne pourrait pas être remplacé.
De la presse écrite?
Oui.
Vous connaissez la capacité d'un algorythme à aggréger de l'information et à écrire un article?
Mais, un algorythme ne remplacera jamais ce que moi je vais chercher dans de la presse écrite.
A savoir, non pas seulement de l'information mais du reportage, de la pensée, du jugement même.
Voilà, c'est ça qu'est censée apporter la presse, qu'elle ne fait pas parce que :
le reportage, on n'a plus d'argent pour en faire ;
la pensée, encore faut-il pouvoir l'articuler !
Donc voilà, c'est tout. Donc je pense qu'il y a aujourd'hui une forme de journalisme low-cost qui est en train de se développer.
Une uberisation du journalisme?
Ah mais totalement !
Il suffit de voir comment dans les rédactions de presse quotidienne, le modèle du numérique est en train de dicter sa loi aux journalistes de presse écrite.
De même que les chaînes d'information en continu ont dicté leur mode de fonctionnement au reste du journalisme.
C'est-à-dire que le temps long, le recul, sont en train de disparaître.
Ce qui compte aujourd'hui pour un journaliste c'est de produire le plus vite possible pour faire de l'alerte smartphone.
Mais même dans des grands quotidiens nationaux. Donc je pense que c'est contre cela qu'il faut lutter.
Et d'ailleurs, vous avez un travail journalistique sur le Net qui arrive à lutter contre ça, mais qui pour l'instant vivote.
Ne serait-ce que ce matin dans ma revue de presse, je citais le site "Ulyces"
qui est entre le journalisme et l'édition, mais qui fait du temps long, qui fait de l'enquête, qui fait du récit.
Il me semble que ça c'est un modèle, c'est une des formes du journalisme qui malheureusement est en train d'être erradiquée des média classiques.
Et pourquoi?
Question économique.
Pas une question de...
Et question aussi de capacité du public à se donner la peine de lire.
J'ai interviewé le directeur de la télévison publique russe en Russie.
Bon, je l'ai un peu chauffé hein, sur la liberté de la presse, sur des gens qui disparaissent...
Oui ce sont des choses qui arrivent...
Bon ça arrive mais bon, comment se comportaient les journalistes russes pour enquêter? Des choses comme ça.
Et puis en partant il me dit par l'intermédiaire de son traducteur "Tu sais, il faut donner non pas ce que les gens ont besoin mais ce que les gens veulent".
Question philosophique ça.
En France on leur donne quoi aux gens?
Karl Popper s'est posé la question de savoir si en matière de télévision par exemple, la démocratie consitait à donner aux gens ce qu'ils veulent.
Et, je crois que, tout ça est... moi je ne crois pas.
Alors on fait quoi?
Pourquoi? Mais je précise pourquoi : parce que sans un peuple éduqué la démocratie c'est la tyrannie des imbéciles.
Donc donner aux gens ce qu'ils veulent en faisant en sorte qu'ils ne veuillent que des choses simples, distrayantes, faciles,
parce qu'on les a abruti et qu'on a fait en sorte de détruire l'outil d'éducation qu'est l'école, ce n'est plus de la démocratie.
Et si l'on passe le point de non-retour d'abêtissement de la population?
Et bien on sort de la démocratie et c'est bien le problème et c'est bien ce qui m'inquiête et on n'en est pas loin.
L'état d'urgence pour vous c'est quoi?
L'état d'urgence c'est une des façons d'agiter la masse, de faire croire au bon peuple qu'on le protège, en évitant de se poser les véritables problèmes.
La déchéance de nationalité?
Même chose. Ca fait quand même un mois que les média sont à temps plein sur une question absolument ridicule.
Il faut que ça passe, c'est tout. Pourquoi il faut déchoir quelqu'un de sa nationalité?
Est-ce que vous avez étudié un peu, à partir de 2001, tous les "executive order" américains, le "Patriot act"
et tout l'arsenal législatif autour de l'emprisonnement, la torture, le kidanapping et l'assassinat?
Est-ce que ça n'est pas plus facile pour un état français maintenant d'aller demander des informations de façon un peu plus... Prédatrice sur un détenu?
Parce que comme il ne sera plus protégé par notre constitution, il aura une extra-territorialité de sa justice.
Est-ce que c'est pour ça que les média sont en train de nous en faire manger pendant un mois?
C'est-à-dire que après, on va aller attraper les terrorristes, et puis il faudra les faire parler.
Mais si l'on fait parler un terrorriste qui est d'origine française, on va peut-être pas pouvoir le torturer comme on pouvait torturer un "sauvage" déchu de sa nationalité.
Alors, peut-être suis-je un peu naïve ou peut-être suis-je beaucoup plus pessimiste que vous sur les journalistes,
Ca m'étonnerait !
Mais j'ai tendance à penser que ça n'est même pas ça le problème.
Ah oui?
Oui. Que le problème, la raison pour laquelle les journalistes s'agitent depuis un mois là-dessus,
c'est parce que le marigot politicien les fascinent.
C'est parce que de savoir si Hollande a mis un poignard dans le dos de Sarkozy et si la droite va se faire trianguler par...
C'est "Plus belle la vie" politique? Santa barbara, Tele novella?
Mais évidemment, c'est uniquement ça. Uniquement.
Ils vont pas du tout aller réfléchir aux implications réelles.
Comment on fait pour sanctionner ces gens-là?
Dans le journalisme classique, il y a une hirérarchie implicite. Tout en haut il y a les journalistes politiques.
Les autres c'est le Lumpenprolétariat, en particulier les journalistes sur les questions de société etc...
Pourant c'est le plus important...
Or, les journalistes politiques sont, on va dire, des commentateurs sportifs.
"Machin a courru plus vite que l'autre..."
C'est qui le meilleur commentateur?
Meilleur commentateur, ça je ne sais pas parce que justement ça m'ennuie profondément le commentaire sportif.
Ce sont des spécialistes de la vie politique des partis. Sauf quand vous regardez là aussi le fonctionnement d'une rédaction,
quand il s'agit d'aller interviewer un homme politique en vue, on se fout de savoir quelle est sa spécialité.
On envoie les journalistes politiques.
Qui vont évidemment être incapables de l'interroger sur les réelles décisions politiques qu'il prend.
Vous savez dans une rédaction de journal on est capable d'aller interroger le ministre de l'éduction nationale sans demander au journaliste spécialiste d'éducation.
Ca arrive. Parce que ce qui compte c'est que les journalistes politiques viennent lui demander
"Alors vous postulez à quoi?", "Alors quelle est votre tactique pour battre machin?", etc.
Il n'y a que ça qui les intéresse.
Donc je pense aussi que ça explique beaucoup du fnctionnement des journaux. Voyez par-delà les questions purement idéologiques de fond.
C'est-à-dire que justement, il n'y a pas d'idéologie. Il n'y a pas de réflexion.
Ce sont des coquilles creuses? Ou se sont simplement des "putes à fric"? Ils courrent après le fric?
Alors après il y a des questions de génération. C'est-à-dire qu'il y a eu toute une tradition du grand journalisme politique à la française,
qui d'ailleurs a bien du mal à comprendre que la proximité avec son sujet peut parfois être très problématique.
Mais les jeunes journalistes aujourd'hui ont tendance à reproduire ça. Alors en étant un peu plus mordant, en étant un petit peu plus rentre-dedans.
Moins dans la conivence... Mais tout de même ils vont, pour le coup, pêcher par absence de culture politique, absence de culture historique,
qui leur interdira de faire preuve ne serait-ce que du minimum de mémoire
qui permet d'interroger un homme politique sur ses choix, sur son parcours, sur la cohérence de ce qu'il fait.
Est-ce que c'est le principe de Peter appliqué à votre profession?
C'est possible. Je pense que c'est surtout...
Vous pouvez nous rappeller le principe de Peter?
Le principe de Peter c'est le principe d'incompétence. C'est l'idée qu'on atteint au bout d'un moment son seuil d'incompétence si je ne me trompe, c'est bien ça?
Si mes souvenirs sont bons c'est qu'on place les éléments les plus incompétents à des hauts postes parce que c'est là qu'ils font le moins de mal.
Voilà, c'est ce qu'on appelle l'éviction par le haut aussi, que j'ai vu beaucoup pratiquée.
Et c'est aussi le fait que... Plutôt dans ce principe il y a l'idée que chacun va monter les échelons,
jusqu'au moment où il ne pourra pas monter parce qu'on voit qu'il a atteint son seuil d'incompétence.
Sauf qu'une fois qu'il a atteint son seuil d'incompétence, il est là.
Joffrin, il est incompétent?
Est-ce que Joffrin est incompétent, je ne dirais pas ça.
Enfin, je n'ai jamais trouvé que les résultats qu'il avait donnés à la tête des rédactions qu'il avait dirigées étaient fulgurants.
Je veux dire, en termes même de nombre de lecteurs, de développement d'un titre...
Après, chez Laurent Joffrin, il y a un problème idéologique.
Moi j'ai du mal avec quelqu'un qui considère que son travail est de faire en sorte d'abord de défendre mordicus la politique d'un président de la république qui a trahi toutes ses promesses de campagne.
Et ensuite, de criminaliser tous ceux qui pourraient éventuellement s'opposer à cela ou faire valoir qu'il y a d'autres politiques possibles.
Sa façon de jetter l'opprobre sur les opinions qui le dérangent, c'est ça?
Bah oui, de traiter carrément de crypto-fascistes à peu-près tous ceux qui ne rentrent pas de le cadre, on va dire, de la gentille social-démocratie
qui d'ailleurs n'est même plus une sociale-démocratie mais du libéralisme pur.
Quand il me dit "il ya énormément d'informations qui passent, il n'y a pas de police de la pensée, il n'y a pas de cycle orwellien du journalisme..."
Oui, ça s'appelle se moquer du monde, je pense.
Il doit être déconnecté?
Je pense que, malheureussment ce genre de personnages arrive très sincèrement à se persuader de ce qu'il dit.
C'est-à-dire qu'il est convaincu qu'il est en lutte contre une France rance, nauséabonde...
Parce que dans ces cas-là vous avez remarqué qu'il y a quand même une sensibilité olfactive assez marquée chez ces gens-là.
Ce sont toujours les adjectifs olfactifs qui prévalent.
Et donc, je pense qu'il est intimement convaincu d'être dans le camp du bien face aux salauds. Vraiment.
Et qu'il fait oeuvre de salubrité publique en essyant à tout prix d'empêcher que puisse surgir une alternative.
Ne comprenant pas évidemment, que sa façon de renvoyer au front national toute personne qui ne pense pas exactement dans la ligne libérale qui est la sienne,
laisse justement le monopole de l'alternative au front national. Mais après tout, c'est ce qui est recherché je pense.
C'est l'idée que l'on a besoin d'un diable. On va pouvoir agiter ce diable et tant qu'il existe, on continue soi-même à exister.
On va passer sur la politique étrangère. La France, qui va intervenir un peu partout, la France qui n'a plus beaucoup de sous...
Des terrorristes qui frappent maintenant sur le territoire, une politique étrangère sans aucune remise en question...
Non seulement sans aucune remise en question mais qui poursuit depuis des années maintenant,
un alignement sur les Etats-unis qui est la négation absolue de tout ce qui avait été sa tradition diplomatique.
Et qui le fait en plus pour les pires raisons qui soient. Tout simplement parce qu'il n'y a plus d'argent.
Et parce que, du coup, on pense qu'il faut aller prendre les capitaux là où ils sont, c'est-à-dire en Arabie saoudite et au Qatar.
Je crois très sincèrement que notre diplomatie est dictée par notre besoin d'argent.
Et que, pour faire illusion ensuite, on s'invente des guerres un peu partout. En n'ayant pas d'ailleurs les moyens suffisants pour les mener.
Dans la mesure où le budget militaire a été réduit de façon ahurisssante.
Rincé !
Mais... Nettoyé ! Mais comme la posture du chef de guerre, ça marche encore en France
et que ça permet de gagner des points dans les sondages, tout à coup on s'aperçoit que c'est pas mal, l'armée.
Si vous aviez à vous positionner dans cette phrase :
"A ces politiques qui leur crèvent les yeux ou à ces foules aveugles"?
Redites-moi la phrase...
Si j'interprète bien la phrase, il s'agit de savoir si c'est de la responsabilité des politiques ou si c'est de la responsabilité des gens qui acceptent?
Je pense que c'est un jeu en miroir.
Je pense que les foules aveugles en effet, ont accepté depuis des années de se désaisir du pouvoir que leur avait donné la démocratie.
C'est du misérabilisme de l'impuissance?
C'est une forme de... on va dire de paresse entretenue par tout un système.
C'est-à-dire que je pense que le principe de la société de consommation et de spectacle est évidemment
d'encourager cette paresse et de la faire prospérer. De développer chez les gens, les pulsions immédiates...
Animales?
Oui, oui bien sûr. Le principe même de la consommation, incité par la publicité, c'est ça.
C'est de jouer sur les pulsions en activant des stimulis pour justement éviter toute réflexion, tout recul. On est dans la manipulation pure.
Quand Patrick Le lay explique que son métier consiste à vendre à Coca-cola du temps de cerveau humain disponible,
il a résumé le fonctionnement de la démocratie aujourd'hui.
Les gens sont cons?
On les a rendu cons ! On fait en sorte qu'ils soient cons.
Moi j'ai un très très grand respect pour les savoirs non-scolaires, les savoirs non-universitaires.
Et je pense que l'humanité a développé ces savoirs pendant des siècles, de façon admirable.
J'entendais l'autre jour, une rediffusion des très vieux extraits de "Bonjour monsieur le maire" de Pierre Bonte.
Ca paraît totalement ringard, il allait dans le fin-fond de la France paysanne dans les années 1960
et il interrogeait des gens dont on comprenait qu'ils avaient une intelligence et une masse de culture absolument énorme.
C'est une culture qui a été erradiquée. Qui a été erradiquée par quoi? Par un triptyque : télévision, publicité, grande distribution.
Ce qui a petit à petit englué ces gens chez eux, devant leur télé, en rompant tous les liens sociaux qu'ils pouvaient avoir avec le monde qui les entourait.
Et qui les a incité à rêver de ce qu'ils allaient pouvoir trouver le Samedi au supermarché.
Je pense qu'il y a là une aliénation absolument monstrueuse.
Cette catatonie émotionnelle, créée dans la population par cet anesthésique qu'est la presse, ce show, ce cirque,
crée maintenant une incompréhension entre les flux de migrants, la douleur des migrants, la souffrance des migrants.
Ca va se matérialiser comment, quand les gens vont commencer à prendre conscience de la réalité des souffrances mondiales qui se déplacent?
Qui s'est mise en ordre de marche?
Ca peut être extrêmement dangereux. Ca peut être extrêmement dangereux parce que tout cela n'est absolument pas pensé ou préparé.
Si.
Parce que...
Le "Stabilo Due", exercice suisse à partir de 2012 : fermeture intérgale du territoire, de ses frontières contre un afflux massif de migrants en provenant d'Espagne, d'Italie, de Grèce, de France...
Les militaires réfléchissent quand même à ça.
Oui. Mais je pense que les politiques ne réfléchissent pas. Je pense qu'il n'y a pas de réflexion politique sur ce qu'implique les déplacements de population,
qui ont été en grande partie causés par des décisions occidentales absolument délirantes.
Nous sommes quand même en train de payer la guerre d'Irak, la guerre de Libye, qui ont déstabilisé totalement des pays, dans une irresponsabilité totale.
Donc aujourd'hui, cette soufrance provoquée va destabiliser mécaniquement les sociétés européennes et tout cela n'est absolument pas anticipé.
Vous croyez à la balkanisation de l'Europe?
Oui. Je le crains. Je crains qu'il y ait un éclatement total des nations et des luttes violentes parce qu'on voit monter la violence aujourd'hui.
On voit que dans l'ensemble des pays européens, il y a des radicalisations de toute part.
Chaque camp idéologique, ethnique, se radicalise et montre de moins en moins d'empathie, de moins en moins de capacité à penser les choses politiquement.
Donc je crains énormément que dans l'avenir, il puisse y avoir véritablement des erruptions de violence.
On sait très bien, l'histoire nous montre qu'une société censément civilisée peut basculer dans la barbarie extrêmement rapidement.
Jusque-là tout va bien?
Ecoutez, moi je ne pense pas que tout aille bien mais tant qu'on a des dirigeants qui se rassurent en s'imaginant qu'ils s'en tireront
et en ne réfléchissant pas plus loin qu'à 1 ou 2 mois ou au mieux, à l'élection suivante, ça continuera.
Mais très honnêtement, je pense que c'est pour ça que notre responsabilité notamment en tant que journaliste est d'essayer de penser le temps long.
C'est d'essayer jutement de décrypter des mouvements qui sont des mouvement intellectuels, des mouvements de pensée, des mouvements d'opinion bien plus vastes.
Mais pour ça, ça nécessite d'abord de prendre le temps de réfléchir, ça nécessite aussi la culture suffisante, justement pour être capable de faire le lien entre les évènements.
On va changer de sujet. Edward Snowden. Ca vous fait penser à quoi?
Hum... Comment vous dire à quoi ça me fait penser? Ca me fait penser d'abord à une forme de lâcheté terrible de la France, ça oui.
Dans la façon dont a été gérée son... Dans la façon dont la France a refusé de lui venir en aide.
L'asile?
Oui oui. Que vous dire de plus?
La NSA?
Je pense que nous avons totalement renoncé à faire prévaloir, on va dire une idépendance.
Toi en tant que journaliste, tu fais comment pour... Vous faites comment pour protéger vos sources?
La caste journalistique ne sait pas chiffrer ses mails, la caste journalistique a une connaissance parcellaire, voire vaporisée du milieu numérique.
J'ai beau discuter avec eux, leur expliquer que la confidentialité d'une enquête, c'est important.
Que vous pouvez mettre en danger toute une salle de rédaction avec une demi-clé USB. Ils sont complètement à l'Ouest. Est-ce-qu'il y a des cours?...
Je connais 2 journalistes dans le numérique qui font correctement leur boulot et on leur manifeste notre respect, Jean-Marc Manach et Marc [...].
Il y en a d'autres ! Mais ces deux-là essayent des prêcher un petit peu leurs confrères... C'est...
Vous savez chiffrer un mail?
Non bien sûr, mais vous savez, moi je ne suis pas une journaliste d'investigation.
Non. Mais vous êtes présidente d'un think-tank maintenant.
C'est vrai. Et donc en effet, je pense que quand on est journaliste d'investigation, il y a ce genre de précaution à prendre. Mais je vais être très honnête avec vous :
Moi, ma pratique journalistique, elle est d'un autre ordre. C'est-à-dire qu'il y a différentes formes de journalisme. Je n'incarne pas le journalisme d'investigation.
Moi je suis quelqu'un qui essaye, on va dire de penser le monde, tout simplement. Et d'en décrypter les mouvement idéologiques.
Alors Snowden, c'est quoi? C'est un mouvement idéologique, c'est la réminiscence de l'affaire Farwell, mais côté américain cette fois-ci?
C'est... Qu'est-ce-que c'est?
Oui, et c'est la révélation absolue d'une forme d'impérialisme extrêmement puissant et extrêmement violent,
d'un rouleau-compresseur, malgré tout sous les apparences débonnaires d'une puissance en temps de paix. Mais il n'y a pas de paix.
On a récemment interviewé le ministre conseiller de l'ambassade de Russie et puis juste après son patron, l'ambassadeur Alexandre Orlov.
Ambassadeur de la Fédération de Russie. Bon, comme on est un peu taquins, on appelé les américains derrière. On leur a proposé le même deal, avec les même choses.
Et on s'est rendu compte que pour avoir une interview de l'ambassadrice américaine, c'était déjà 10 minutes maximum.
Et que c'était mieux d'envoyer les questions juste avant. Quand on leur a dit qu'on venait de YouTube et que l'on ne procédait pas comme ça
et que toutes les interactions que l'on allait avoir avec eux allaient être publiques, ils ont commencé à tousser.
Comment ça se fait que les journalistes acceptent d'aller, je vais pas dire "tapiner" parce que donner ses questions avant, c'est tapiner non? C'est quoi?
Alors c'est compliqué, ça dépend dans quel cadre. Et puis ça dépend si c'est toutes les questions que vous donnez et si ça interdit les relances après, vous voyez?
C'est-à-dire : est-ce-que j'ai déjà eu à donner mes question avant, non. Jamais. Mais, en tout cas pas en télé !
Un thème quoi ! Vous donnez les axes genre nous on dit : géopolitique, internet, finance, terrorrisme...
Voilà, c'est ça, pas plus.
Donner les question avant, comment vous dire?
J'essaye de réfléchir à comment on peut biaiser face à ça. Parce qu'une ambassadrice américaine réclame qu'on lui donne les questions avant, ça ne me surprend pas.
Elle ne réclame pas. Elle préfère "c'est préférable"...
Oui oui, bien sûr, on est bien d'accord. De même que j'ai déjà vu des cabinets de ministre expliquer non pas qu'ils voulaient les questions avant,
m'enfin que quand même si on pouvait leur expliquer exactement avant ce qu'il allait se passer, c'était mieux.
Il y a toujours moyen de donner 2-3 trucs et de... Voyez? C'est-à-dire que ça ne m'étonne pas qu'ils jouent leur partition.
La question c'est est-ce que le journaliste en face accepte de rentrer totalement dans le jeu ou est-ce qu'il biaise? Voyez?
Donc là en l'occurence, dans un cadre comme le votre où vous êtes dans une interview, vous ne pouvez pas accepter ça. Sinon vous vous privez de l'interview.
C'est ça.
Mais sans doute vaut-il mieux se priver de l'interview que d'avoir une langue de bois absolue. C'est tout, c'est un choix.
Oui. Qu'est-ce-que vous pouvez nous donner comme conseil pour quand-même y aller?
Parce que... On va vous expliquer rapide, on a shooté Axelle Lemaire pendant la loi renseignement, qui ne voulait pas répondre aux télés,
comme on a une forte communauté de hackers et de geeks derrière nous et qu'on est fortement enracinés dans cette "guilde",
on lui a posé clairement les choses : on lui a dit "nous on va dire qu'on a essayé de vous parler", méfiez-vous s'il y a 100 000 personnes qui débarquent sur votre compte Twitter, on ne sera pas responsable.
Quand ils ont vu nos partenaires, ils ont dit "oups, ils ont des partenaires qui ont 2 millions de visiteurs uniques par mois, c'est compliqué".
Elle a joué la transparence, elle a tenu sa parole. Dans les autres ministères, c'est compliqué. Donc est-ce que vous nous conseillez de continuer à faire les mercenaires?
Oui.
Oui?
Oui bien sûr. De toutes façons, je pense que vous avez une arme absolue qui est le caractère immédiatement mesurable de votre puissance.
C'est tout. La presse écrite n'a plus tout à fait ça. La presse classique, quand je dit "presse écrite" c'est aussi la radio et la télé ;
Et sur des choses beaucoup moins immédiats que ne peuvent l'être les réseaux sociaux, donc si le rapport de force s'inverse, il ne faut pas hésiter à l'utiliser.
C'est un rapport de force. L'information, il faut aller la chercher, le questionnement, il peut être violent et il doit l'être parfois, donc...
On peut s'engueuler encore? On peut s'en mettre plein la tête, une vraie joute oratoire?
Mais j'espère, j'espère bien. Le drame aujourd'hui, c'est que la plupart des gens n'acceptent de venir débattre qu'avec ceux avec qui ils sont déjà d'accord.
Vous, vous voudriez débattre avec Acrimed?
Oui bien sûr !
Tout de suite?
Oui.
D'accord.
Bien sûr, moi je n'ai aucun problème.
Si vous aviez à laisser un conseil aux jeunes générations, une bouteille à la mer sur internet?
Nous on a le prisme à moyen terme, à long terme. On essaye de détecter les signaux faibles et on essaye aussi de laisser
des préconisations à la jeunesse qui fume des pétards à 3h du matin et qui regarde des émissions de géopolitique.
Un conseil pour les jeunes générations?
Lisez Thucydide.
Vraiment.
Je ne peux vous dire que ça : lisez et en en particulier, révisez l'histoire antique, l'histoire romaine, l'histoire grecque.
C'est une manne pour comprendre justement ce que c'est réellement que la géopolitique, ce que c'est que les rapports de force.
Quand vous lisez dans "La guerre du Péloponnèse" la façon dont Athènes a traité la petite île de Mélos qui voulait rester neutre dans la guerre,
Qui ne voulait surtout pas se mêmer du conflit et qu'Athènes leur a dit "Non mais attendez, nous on ne veut pas de neutralité, si vous n'êtes pas avec nous, vous êtes contre nous".
Georges Bush...
Et ils ont envahi Mélos et ils ont réduit en esclavage toute la population. Mais c'est une explication absolument extraodinaire du mode de fonctionnement de l'impérialisme.
Si vous regardez le fonctionnement d'Athènes, la façon dont ils appliquent et dont ils sont très fiers
d'appliquer en leur sein, la démocratie mais la façon dont ils traitent leurs alliés, vous comprenez d'abord ce que c'est que...
Que ce ne sont pas des alliés.
Voilà, que ce ne sont pas des alliés mais des subordonnés. Et ça vous rappelle un impérialisme actuel assez marqué.
Et ensuite ça vous explique pourquoi ça s'est effondré. Parce que ça finit par s'effondrer.
Oui... Ségolène Royal au Quai d'Orsay, ça vous fait penser à quoi?
*Rires* Pardon...
La bravitude?
C'est... Oui, oui oui.
Vous avez d'autres choses à nous poser, des questions à nous poser, vous à votre tour?
Des questions, oui, bien sûr. Vous êtes non-journalistes et vous êtes extrêmement critiques sur le journalisme, ce que je comprends parfaitement.
Et je le suis aussi. Est-ce que pour autant, vous estimez qu'il faut que la presse et les média tels qu'ils existent disparaissent?
Oui.
Oui?
A 100%
Je vais délayer la réponse : quand vous avez trahi la confiance de quelqu'un, jamais vous ne pouvez revenir en arrière.
Oui, ça je crois que c'est vrai. Je crois que c'est vrai. En même temps...
Et je pense d'ailleurs qu'il y a moyen aujourd'hui en tout cas de réfléchir à une façon de développer sur le net, l'ensemble de ce qu'apporte...
Je disais tout à l'heure que je pense que pour l'instant, le travail que fait le journalisme de presse écrite notamment, on ne le trouve pas sur le net, sous la même forme.
C'est vrai, je le pense. Pour autant, je pense qu'à terme, de toutes façons ça se passera. On est dans une phase de transition.
Et ce que moi je viens chercher dans la presse, je crois que ça peut surgir aussi de diverses manières sur le net.
Simplement, c'est un modèle économique, c'est une question de modèle économique. Comment on arrive à faire vivre ça.
Pour l'instant malheureusement, il faut beaucoup d'argent pour payer un type qui aille faire un reportage au long court.
Je ne sais pas si on a trouvé la solution pour que ce soit rentable. Non.
Vous avez d'autres questions à nous poser?
J'imagine que vous n'êtes pas... Je pense que nous n'avons pas la même culture... Très honnêtement, je n'ai pas une culture des nouvelles technologies.
Je n'ai pas... Et pour l'instant je n'ai pas eu le temps de m'intéresser suffisamment à ces problématiques.
Et à toute l'implication que ça peut avoir sur les questions, notamment de journalisme d'investigation.
Enfin ce n'est pas que ça ne m'intéresse pas, je m'y suis intéressée mais pas autant que je le voudrais.
C'est-à-dire que je ne serai jamais péremptoire sur ces questions-là parce que j'estime qu'il y a des choses que je ne maîtrise pas suffisament.
J'ai une culture trop classique pour ça.
Mais... Je ne sais pas si ça tourne encore. C'est quoi une culture trop classique?
On va dire que je suis quelqu'un de l'écrit. Mais véritablement. Quelqu'un qui va s'intéresser spontanément au récit, à la pensée, à l'idéologie, voilà.
Je suis profondément, je pense, imprégnée de culture littéraire et de culture historique et c'est pour ça que je pense que
j'ai envie d'ouvrir le comité Orwell à des journalistes qui auront un autre type de culture que la mienne.
C'est-à-dire qui seront bien plus au fait des modes de fonctionnement des réseaux sociaux, vous voyez,
tout ce qui concerne le hacking par exemple est quelque chose qui méchappe. Je ne sais pas comment ça fonctionne.
Ca fonctionne très simplement, hein.
Oui bien sûr, mais les choses ne sont jamais "simples". J'aime comprendre, j'aime comprendre jusqu'au bout.
Elles sont simples.
Donc quand on cherche à compredre, ça n'est jamais simple.
Ou quand on est passionné c'est toujours simple.
Voilà !
Ah, j'ai peut-être une petite question encore...
L'information de très haute qualité dont vous rêvez, que vous professez, l'information qui fait appel à l'intelligence des gens,
Comment peut-elle être mise en place dans un système où les média sont à but lucratif et en concurrence?
C'est... C'est toute l'ambivalence, bien-sûr. C'est-à-dire que, je le disais tout à l'heure, ce sont des entreprises. Mais ce ne sont pas des entreprises comme les autres.
Donc, ça ne peut fonctionner que dans un système où il y a un public éclairé ; qui a envie de payer pour cette information, pour cette réflexion de qualité.
Y a-t-il encore aujourd'hui, un public de lecteurs? Non.
Non mais, Natacha, le principe de catatonie intellectuelle. C'est simple, vous mettez quelqu'un sous pression, vous le harcelez de peines et de maux (mots) :
"crise financière", "perte de boulot", "problèmes à l'école", "terrorrisme", "crise nucléaire", "pollution aux pesticides" et on en passe et des meilleures.
Qu'est-ce qu'il se passe? Il y a un effet de repli, tout le monde le sait, du moins les gens déjà éclairés le savent.
Oui, bien sûr.
Et quand on extrapôle le raisonnement, on sait pertinnemment que ce sont des belles paroles de dire que "On ne peut avoir qu'un public éclairé" mais il y en a de moins en moins.
C'est ce que je viens de vous dire, bien sûr qu'il y en a de moins en moins.
Nous on a le dynamique de lâcher prise. C'est-à-dire que... On vous laisse encore une chance, vous les journalistes, de laver votre honneur. De laver votre profession.
Le cercle Orwell pour nous, le comité Orwell, au départ on l'a un peu mal pris que vous vous appeliez comme ça parce que c'est lourd symbolique pour nous.
Et on s'est dit quand même, ils essaient de survivre, ils essaient de réveiller, alors c'est peut-être pas tous les journalistes
et qu'il y en a une qui a décidé de sortir parce qu'elle a une paire de balloches un peu plus endurcies que la majeure partie de sa caste.
Et on vous laisse faire, on va peut-être essayer de vous aider, du moins regarder la profession journalistique avec un peu plus de bienveillance.
Mais après, vous serez relégués définitivement avec les politiques, les lobbyistes et ainsi de suite.
C'est-à-dire que vous allez devenir la cible, vraiment, de gens pertinents sur l'outil numérique et ça risque de très mal se passer.
Donc battez-vous, battez-vous.
Oui, mais d'abord je vais vous dire une chose : je ne me suis jamais sentie appartenir à aucune caste ni à aucune corporation. Je n'ai pas l'esprit de caste.
Vous n'avez jamais acheté de voiture avec votre carte de presse?
Non.
D'accord.
Euh... Non. Pourquoi on achète une voiture avec une carte de presse?
Parce que vous pouvez acheter un machine à laver aussi avec une carte de presse.
Non. Pardon, je dois vraiment être très con !
Je vous conseille de... Oui, vous appellez [...] vous appellez [...], vous dites que vous êtes journaliste, vous avez une carte de presse et hop, vous avez une réduction.
Et bien je ne savais pas vous voyez. Vous me l'apprenez, c'est sympa !
*Rires* On peut en profiter?
Ah oui oui, si vous voulez mais non, j'ai loupé des trucs. Comme quoi les journalistes sont quand même parfois les moins bien informés...
Non, c'est...
Non sérieusement non, je ne sais pas, je dois avoir d'abord un vieux fond d'éducation morale
De respect peut-être.
Moi j'ai eu une éducation un peu janséniste, il y a des trucs qui ne se font pas... Bon voilà. Et honnêtement je n'ai jamais eu l'esprit de corps.
J'ai été prof aussi, je n'étais pas plus corporatiste côté prof que côté journaliste, voilà.
Donc je ne me sens absolument pas comptable de ce que font les journalistes en général.
C'est bien.
Ce qui m'intéresse c'est de savoir comment moi je vais essayer de faire mon boulot à peu près honnêtement. Et de faire en sorte de...
Oh, vous bossez au Figaro quand même non?
Ah, je ne suis plus journaliste au Figaro, je suis chroniqueuse extérieure.
D'accord.
Je ne suis pas salariée de la rédaction, d'ailleurs je n'y mets pas les pieds parce que je ne suis pas journaliste au Figaro.
Je l'ai été pendant 3 ans. Sur les questions d'éducation.
Au comité Orwell, on vous a objecté que vous travaillez pour un marchand d'armes. C'est quoi votre avis là-dessus?
Mon avis c'est que malheureusement aujourd'hui en effet, une bonne partie des média appartiennent à des grands groupes industriels et en particulier des groupes qui vendent des armes.
Plutôt que de m'objecter le Figaro on aurait pu m'objecter d'ailleurs Europe1 où là, d'ailleurs je ne suis pas plus salariée...
Enfin, je ne suis pas plus en CDI mais je suis salariée là pour le coup.
Simplement, j'ai commencé mon travail de journaliste à Marianne, qui est l'un des rares journaux indépendants.
Et j'en ai gardé l'idée que en effet, dans un monde idéal, il fallait aller vers les média qui étaient les plus indépendants.
Et que ça permettait plus de liberté. Pour autant d'abord, c'est quand même à Marianne que je me suis fait placardiser pour mes idées.
A partir du départ de Jean-François Kahn. Le journal s'est recentré vers quelque chose de gentillement "gauche bien-pensante", social-démocrate.
Donc je n'avais plus ma place. Alors qu'au Figaro, j'ai pu, quand j'étais journaliste sur les questions d'éducation, dire tout le mal que je pensais des lois Chatel.
Je ne me suis jamais fait taper sur les doigts. La seule fois où je me suis fait taper sur les doigts, c'était quand
j'étais invitée comme éditorialiste sur les plateaux de télévision, moi qui n'étais que rubricarde d'éducation.
Ce qui fait partie des hasards de la vie, bon, ça s'est trouvé comme ça.
Alors "taper sur les doigts" ça s'est manifesté comment?
Enfin, "taper sur les doigts" non. C'était un coup de téléphone d'un supérieur hiérarchique disant "écoute, la prochaine fois essaie d'y aller mollo".
Comment il s'appelle?
Je ne balance pas les supérieurs hiérarchiques.
D'accord.
Non, ça j'estime que ça ne se fait pas, voilà.
Non?
Mais il suffit de savoir que c'est un supérieur hiérarchique au Figaro, au Figaro de l'époque.
Non mais on ne sait jamais, si nous on tombe sur le nom sur internet, on pourra peut-être essayer de lui envoyer un petit mail. Pour le remercier.
Non et vous savez sur quel sujet c'était? La guerre en Libye.
Oh bah tiens, pour changer.
Voilà, parce que j'étais sur le plateau de Thierry Ardisson et que j'avais... J'étais là pour parler bio-éthique parce que l'invité était René Frydman.
Et ils avaient invité 2 personnalités amies de René Frydman donc l'abbé de la Morandais et Bernard Kouchner.
Et il se trouve que la discussion arrive pile au moment où la France commençait à intervenir en Libye.
Et Bernard a sorti son sac de riz !
Bah voilà ! Et il nous a expliqué que c'était merveilleux et qu'on allait sauver le monde.
Oui, la démocratie pour les petites filles...
Voilà, et là je lui ai dit "écoutez, ça me parait quand même un petit peu présomptueux, excusez-moi on a fait quelques ânneries en Irak,
on est peut-être pas obligés non plus de recommencer et de recommencer en étant persuadés que cette fois-ci ça va être merveilleux".
Donc le minimum c'est d'avoir un tout petit peu de prudence.
Et là ils m'ont tous regardé en se demandant d'où je sortais... Il y avait un côté, j'avais fait intrusion dans un dîner de gens bien et, qui l'a invitée celle-là?
D'ailleurs ça a été la question après.
Non ?!
"Mais pourquoi? Mais il faut inviter des gens sérieux quand même un petit peu", voilà.
Mais, ça m'a vallu de me retrouver à On n'est pas couché. Puisque Catherine barma était devant sa télé et s'est dit "tiens elle au moins elle sait tenir tête", voilà.
C'est comme ça que je me suis retrouvée à On n'est pas couché.
Est-ce que vous avez déjà réussi à faire partir un invité?
Par exemple Jacques Attali?
Je ne l'ai pas eu à On n'est pas couché Jacques Attali.
Ah oui?
Non. Non non. Mais Jacques Attali, il part souvent.
Oui, c'est facile de le faire partir.
D'expérience, les gens qui quittent les plateaux sont des multi-récidivistes. Donc il n'y a pas grande gloire à faire quitter un plateau.
Oh bah mince alors, on était fiers ! *Rires*
Non, moi le seul qui soit parti quand j'étais à On n'est pas couché, c'était Christophe Hondelatte. Et je n'en n'ai conçu aucune fièreté.
Oh il est gentillet, Christophe, j'aimais beaucoup son journal de 13h, il était très marrant.
Et ça a même été très négatif parce que ça... C'était volontaire de sa part, c'était une façon de se mettre en scène.
De "surjouer", il surjouait? Oui.
Et du coup, ça a donné l'impression... Je venais d'arriver à On n'est pas couché, ça a donné l'impression à beaucoup de gens que évidemment,
cette émission était là pour faire du clash et que j'étais moi-même évidemment une partie de ce système.
Un "suppôt" !
Et don ça a décrédibilisé totalement mon travail.
Ah mince...
Et j'ai été obligée de ramer apès pour essayer de montrer que mon but n'était pas de faire du clash mais
de débattre et d'essayer de penser les problèmes de façon un peu pertinente et honnête.
Si vous aviez une équipe, une "task force" de la matière grise à former, vous mettriez qui dedans?
Et bien des gens que vous ne connaissez pas forcément.
Allez, allez !
Une équipe à former... Enfin, ça dépend, à former pour faire quoi?
L'agence tous risques de l'information.
Agence tous risques de l'information...
Le cannibale Hannibal, qui assumerait Hannibal?
*Rires* Oh écoutez, je ne sais pas, il y a quelques personnes que je respecte beaucoup parmi les journalistes ajourd'hui et qui ne sont pas forcément...
Denis Robert?
Oui, pourquoi pas et puis, quelqu'un comme Vanessa Ratignier par exemple qui a travaillé avec Pierre Péan sur le Qatar, est quelqu'un que je respecte et que j'apprécie.
C'est ce genre de personnes que j'aurais envie de faire travailler si je pouvais me choisir une équipe.
Ceux que vous... impossible de la faire rentrer dans l'équipe, laquelle?
Oh, vous avez quelques heures?
Oui oui, commencez par un nom, ça nous suffira hein !
Non? *Rires* D'accord.
Pff... vous savez, j'en ai croisé tellement...
Il faut nous donner des cibles !
Des "cibles"? Mais je ne fonctionne pas par cibles.
D'accord.
C'est-à-dire que ça n'est pas une question de lâcheté, c'est que je me fous des personnes. Pour moi c'est totalement anecdotique.
Oui mais le vecteur d'idées. Le principe c'est : la personne, certes le messager n'est rien par rapport au message. Mais quand vous êtes dans un théâtre d'opérations, il faut savoir aussi neutraliser les vecteurs.
Vous les journalistes, vous vous faites neutraliser d'une façon acceptée, du moins la plupart se font neutraliser consciemment ou avec leur aval.
Nous, on neutralise les vecteurs. C'est notre plaisir.
Donc quand vous avez un journaliste qui est vecteur d'une mauvaise information ou d'une information qui est biaisée, on commence à s'intéresser au journaliste.
Et on court-circuite ce vecteur-là. Vous n'avez pas un petit nom à nous dire? Celui qui...
Oh ! Je pense que connaissez aussi bien que moi, tous ! *Rires*
Non honnêtement, moi ma façon de fonctionner, mais c'est une façon aussi, et c'est un tort sans doute, très individuelle.
Parce que c'est peut-être parce que j'ai un parcours un peu à part, ma façon de fonctionner a toujours été de faire mon boulot du mieux que je pouvais en suivant une ligne.
Une ligne idéologique, en défendant les valeurs qui sont les miennes, les idées qui sont les miennes.
Il se trouve que j'ai eu le bol de profiter d'un système audiovisuel qui a besoin de mettre des femmes.
Je suis bénéficiaire de la...
Discrimination positive?
Oui, de la discrimination positive... De la parité, c'est tout.
Pour ou contre? Pour ou contre la discrimination positive?
Moi je suis contre la discrimination positive. Je pense qu'il est nécessaire que l'ensemble de la population soit représentée dans les média comme ailleurs.
Mais ça n'est pas par la discrimination positive qu'il faut le faire.
Vous assumez vos opinions... Vous avez une garde rapprochée contre les terrorristes?
Non, pourquoi?
Est-ce que vous comprenez que certains journalistes soient protégés par l'état?
Ecoutez...
Surtout en ce moment?
S'ils ont reçu des menaces de mort oui, je comprends que...
Est-ce que vous pensez que ce dispositif est suffisament puissant pour protéger nos journalistes? Ceux qui font leur boulot?
Est-ce qu'on a mis suffisament de moyens pour protéger les femmes journalistes?
Non. Enfin je pense qu'on a vu que tout dispositif de protection, de toutes façons avait peu de chances de faire face à des attaques de personnes déterminées.
Mais je pense que... Enfin ça dépend de quelle menace vous parlez, de quel type de menace?
Alors nous on fait de la veille aussi sur les terrorristes et on voit beaucoup de réseaux s'activer sur les femmes journalistes.
Et on trouve que l'on ne met pas assez le paquet pour les protéger et on en profite pour faire passer un message, voilà.
Oui, c'est possible je pense que...
On va encore en menger pour 30 ans vous savez?
Ah ça c'est sûr, on parle de problèmes de très long terme.
Mais je crains malheureusement que la protection, même si elle est nécessaire ne soit jamais totalement suffisante.
Vous savez manier une arme?
Non mais comme je suis quelqu'un d'extrêmement, comment dire? Certains diraient "anxieux", d'autres peut-être "lucide",
et que je suis en pleine réflexion, limite fascination sur le survivalime *Rires*
Pourquoi "fascination"?
Non c'est une façon de parler... Je plaisante !
Mais j'ai toujours été très intéressée par les réflexions qui essaient d'anticiper ce que peut être justement la chute d'une civilisation.
Ne serait-ce que parce que j'ai conscience que c'est parfaitement possible. Que ça peut arriver.
Et donc il m'arrive de temps en temps de me dire que j'aimerais savoir manier une arme et que c'est quelque chose d'extrêmement utile.
En plus quand j'étais petite, mon père m'emmenait faire des cours de...
Toujours pratiqué dans un cadre légal.
Mais bien entendu. Mais très petite, j'ai arpenté les clubs de tir pour tirer à la carabine...
Quel était votre calibre préféré?
Oh à l'époque, j'étais petite hein ! J'avais 6 ans...
7.65 non? *Rires*
Natacha Polony merci et au plaisir de vous revoir sur notre chaîne Youtube.
Merci de votre invitation ! Merci beaucoup.